and the the other side actually there is
a Regional Secondary and also we have we
did some study our director once asks me
what will happen if you transplant and
same day there will be flood we don't
have any
so how do
you you all the way
the
Dr Dr and also please join please join
okay come on you have to harvest
come
onbody else
har harest I
will
4.9 4.9 4.9 4.9
okay come
on we will hand over the produce to
you whatever we Harvest then we convert
to so we have we have at least 20 me we
Harvest and then convert
toor with at 14%
I think I think Dr M should do the whole
plot while
he's I want to thank for inviting
us his
Harvest
PBS one station on this is on one of the
on form activity so I'd like to
introduce the farmer the farmer Musta
Kamal actually uh this is a this is a
farmer of the BR we have a collaborative
we have partner NGO BR as as I told the
seven NG working with us uh like uh BR I
mentioned the inter Corporation partner
like solidity there is also the ex
director of solidarity the seedling
planted and the same plant remain and
then new
form both
both question is how much of this will
he eat eat and how much of it will he
save to plant next year and how much
will he
sell so he answered because it's a new
variety many people asked him for this
seed so he said he will not
eat so he will keep the
SE so that he can distribute to other
farmers will be
are medium Low Land when they're
expecting flood they would like to grow
11 but the upper region when non
flooding area they will
grow
forch can you ask them
what what they would like
to
they in addition to sub I don't know
something
change do they want do they want to even
hire
you y do they ask them if they get
hungry they like the 11 that is B rice
yeah they like that and because in B
rice stay
the hard and
second another day
water water after in the water
morning could you ask a question to them
so we can hear their answer
oh good good good pair good
pair from Je to farmer field from to
farmer
field yeah that's nice yeah
good sometime we we'll bring him to your
lab also yeah oh that would be great
what is your name why don't you go there
no from Jans to farmer field you who
brought you to the farmer
field b
n n t
a u k u k u m a
r r o u r o u
tump is sep r o
u good
L please from jeans to Pharmacy
hello thank you 1 2
three one
more can I make it smaller P somehow
yes he wants to know that he could see
that the subn is very good is there any
special technology required to grow
someone that he has got down that if you
can get there is some other different
technology
then so that you can get more or it is
the technology same
as the the the suban variety uh behaves
the suban SW behaves the same way as
swna so you can grow the uh the
varieties in the same condition if
there's no flooding they will behave
exactly the same if there's a flooding
then the SW someone will survive better
but otherwise they they perform exactly
the
same one is because in in in the other
tries it didn't really obviously there
was a problem with with
s survival is not the problem problem is
the how many days under
watering it may not actually 12 we are
seeing the check to die it is not then
we are
dising no actually
pan panicle ex is not good